welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and we finally
have some information on the original
young Dan a scene that was supposed to
be in Avengers endgame this scene was in
the initial draft of the film however
the creative team scrapped it before
production began so the scene never made
it to the final cut throughout this
video though I'll be breaking down
everything that happened in the origin
story and giving my thoughts on it there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you're
one of the people that got dusted during
the snap and haven't had a chance to
watch Avengers end game yet because
you're wondering why the love of your
life has left you for happy hogan that i
highly recommend that you turn off now
with that out the way i just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into my breakdown of
the young tunnel scene okay so the scene
originally showed young Thanos pretty
much playing out the events that were
mentioned in infinity war when the
character went to the Council of Titan
and told them his solution to the
population boom this reiterated what
Thanos told dr. strange in the prior
film with the character saying that the
only way to save the planet was to wipe
out half of the population at random so
that the remaining half could thrive the
council obviously hadn't seen the
hashtag Thanos was right so rejected
this idea similar to what we've seen in
films like Man of Steel the original
Superman movie and so on the Senate
out-and-out refused to accept that the
planet is dying and from here Stannis
then leaves Titan slowly watching it
from afar as a caves in itself this
would add more reason as to why it was
off its axis and ended up looking like
the barren landscape that we witnessed
during infinity war now the reason that
this was cut is because one of the above
reasons with the writers of the film
saying that this was far too close to
jor-el pleading with the Council of
Krypton to save the planet I definitely
agree with that as when first hearing
how it was laid out images of the DC
film came to mind which are no Marvel
are trying to be away from the right has
also said that this scene can also be
sort of touched upon in dialogue and
doesn't actually need to be witnessed to
be understood we already know from
infinity war that Dallas's planet was
destroyed due to overpopulation and this
molded is thinking
into believing that this is the only
solution to save all of life in the
galaxy whilst I would have loved to have
seen a young Danice I can understand why
it was cut as it's adding extra runtime
to an already three hour long film going
forward there are actually rumors that
Danice will be appearing in upcoming
Marvel movies most notably the Eternals
which will apparently show a younger
version of the character perhaps even on
Titan for those who don't know Thanos is
an eternal himself who only looks
different because he has the deviant
gene in his body and this is what has
drastically altered his appearance there
is speculation that the Eternals will
actually be set over 35,000 years ago
and that danos will make an appearance
here amongst the ranks of the new cast
though whether this comes to fruition
remains to be seen we did however with
this scene description also get concept
art for the character and how he was
originally meant to look as well as the
other eternals and natives of Titan
which certainly shows the difference
between those with the Debian gene and
those without now whilst this scene was
scrapped I do think that it may return
down the line similar to how the old
Peggy Carter scene was originally
supposed to be in Avengers before being
cut and moved to the Winter Soldier I
would absolutely love to see a younger
version of Thanos and I think this scene
could add a lot of way to basically
showcasing wise the way that he is
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this scene and if you would have
liked to have seen it as well comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my full breakdown of
everything we know so far about the next
Avengers movie in it I go about all of
the leaks on the storyline and who the
main players will be so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more you want to come talk to me about
movies TV shows games and comic books
and you can follow me on twitter at
definition white team it's the best way
to get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this I also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of John wick 3 on blu-ray and all
you have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the deleted scene
in the comment section below the winner
will be chosen at random on September
the 10th and the blu-ray will be shipped
out from then to ever get surprised it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you